bonjour julien double merci de répondre
à nos questions je viens de le voir
pascal descamps se bat pour rapatrier sa
fille malade qui se trouve actuellement
dans un camp syrien avec ses quatre
enfants
humainement comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à cette histoire humainement
on peut tous être touché par la douleur
d'une mère qui a envie de retrouver sa
fille
mais moi j'aimerais que cette dame
j'aimerais qu'on pense d'abord à tous
les parents français qui aimeraient que
leurs enfants victimes du terrorisme
islamiste reviennent sauf que c'est
impossible parce que leurs enfants des
victimes du terrorisme islamiste
ils sont au cimetière ils ne reviendront
jamais jamais aucune grève de la faim
jamais aucune procédure judiciaire ne
fera revenir des filles et des fils de
france qui sont tombés sous les balles
du terrorisme islamiste et c'est ça qui
devrait nous préoccuper
alors moi je j'entends la douleur de
cette dame mais sa fille a fait le choix
délibéré de partir souvent se ranger
sous la bannière noire de l'état
islamique
elle a fait le choix de partir faire le
djihad elle a fait le choix de déclarer
la guerre à la france elle a fait le
choix de commettre ou en tout cas de
cautionner des atrocités
elle a fait le choix tout simplement de
sortir de la communauté nationale de
sortir même de notre civilisation
donc à ce titre là elle n'a pas à
revenir en france
voilà le choix là maintenant elle en
assume les conséquences à la suivit son
son mari si j'ai bien compris donc qui
qui s'est engagé lui aussi donc avec
l'état islamique
encore une fois les djihadistes qui ont
décidé de brûler leurs passeports ne
sont plus français ils doivent payer et
ils doivent assumer les conséquences de
leurs actes et de leurs atrocités
là vous parlez de pascal injustement
pascal descamps avec sa fille pascale
des courtiers qui dit à la rigueur que
ma fille soit puni certes mais mes
petits enfants
votre réaction par rapport à ça à eux
aussi ne faut pas les rats pas très sûr
ne vous rappelle il ya un mois le quai
d'orsay a annoncé le rapatriement de
cette mineure de 2,6
je cite particulièrement vulnérables ses
petits enfants ils ne sont pas
vulnérables
vous savez c'est terrible parce que nous
sommes en guerre tu nous sommes en
guerre contre le terrorisme islamiste
international nous sommes en guerre sur
notre sol nous sommes en guerre
évidemment dans divers pays qu'ils
soient au proche orient ou en afrique
et cette guerre évidemment mais n'est
pas propre
il y a des victimes nous avons payé
assez durement notamment les attentats
islamistes de 170 français sont morts
ces dernières années il faut bien en
prendre conscience et le problème de
faire revenir à la fois c'est cette ga
dist le problème de faire revenir des
enfants aussi qu'ils ont été je dirais
embrigader ou autre cas qui ont été
soumis à des aléas des comportements qui
ont vu des atrocités qui ont tué dans un
climat extrêmement difficile c'est les
faire revenir en france c'est aussi
commettre est en tout cas nourrir un
risque ici pour les pour les français
donc je sais ce que c'est la justice
française est ce que c'est la justice
syrienne la justice irakienne la justice
internationale c'est c'est le pays où
ils ont été arrêtés c'est le pays
aujourd'hui où ils sont en détention qui
doit les juger et qui doit s'intéresser
à leur cas ce n'est pas la france de
récupérer des djihadistes ce n'est pas
la france 2 encore une fois de faire
revenir des personnes qui pour la
plupart d'entre elles continuent leur
djihad quand elles reviennent des études
qui ont été montrées et différents
articles que les djihadistes quand ils
reviennent et quand ils sont incarcérés
dans les prisons françaises la plupart
du temps ils poursuivent ce jeudi à 10
mhz il poursuit suivent leur entreprise
islamistes donc en commettant soit en
propageant cette idéologie mortifère
soit en continuant d attentat que ce
soit en prison on l'a vu avec un stock
de deux surveillants pénitentiaires qui
sont en proie à ces attaques de plus en
plus violente
soit ils vont être relâchés au bout de
quelques années et continueront à être
réincarné une menace pour le peuple
français d'eau qui doivent risques qui
ont donc été rapatriés parce qu'ils
étaient dits vulnérables
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous prêts
qu'est ce que vous proposez
qu'est ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui par
paris pour derrick alizés ces personnes
là on sait qu'ils ont été remis à la
justice un des dès leur arrivée le souci
c'est notamment c'est la politique
d'eric dupond moretti c'est la politique
de faire revenir des bombes à
retardement et des radicaliser des
bombes à retardement ça ne fonctionne
pas je suis je suis désolé mais en tout
cas l'expérience nous prouve et gérer le
principe de précaution devrait inciter
le gouvernement français à ne jamais
faire revenir des djihadistes je ne dis
pas rapatrier parce qu'encore une fois
ils ont brûlé leurs passeports encore
une fois ils ont déclaré la guerre à la
france ils ne sont plus français ils
sont ils sont les surplus français ils
n'ont plus voix rester dans la
communauté nationale et encore une fois
les faire rire qu'à voter oui à la
plupart du temps encore une fois c'est
pour ça que nous avions proposé qu'il y
avait eu un débat sur la déchéance de la
nationalité
quand ils sont encore une fois
binationaux on devrait automatiquement
le retirer leur nationalité française au
regard de l'intelligence avec l'ennemi
se sont rangé sous la bannière d'une
puissance hostile qui déclare la guerre
à la france qui commet des atrocités en
syrie en irak qui commet des attentats
sur notre sol qui défenestre des
homosexuels qui lapide des femmes toute
cette idéologie mortifère de vrais
problèmes de et à des problèmes de santé
comme la fille de
de pascal descamps dont vous vous dites
qu'il n'ya pas de circonstances
atténuantes du tout moi les
circonstances atténuantes je veux
d'abord pensé aux familles et aux pères
et aux mères des victimes du terrorisme
islamiste et je veux penser aussi à qui
est le moins de victimes dans notre pays
nous sommes en guerre contre ce
terrorisme islamiste on l'a encore vu il
ya quelques il ya quelques semaines avec
l'attentât en la basilique de nice on
l'a vu malheureusement et on le sait
avec l'attentât effroyable la
décapitation de sabots elle pâtit donc
il ne faut faire preuve d'aucune
faiblesse dans ce combat là alors oui
évidemment évidemment que nous pouvons
être toucher individuellement par la
douleur de cette mer mais encore une
fois la priorité c'est la protection du
peuple français et pour protéger le
peuple français il faut que les
djihadistes bref en syrie et en irak et
soient jugés d'abord merci julien houle
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du bureau
national du rassemblement national